the following video is a conversation
with Balaji srinivasan he's the author
of a brand new book the network state in
this conversation we do a little bit of
a history lesson we talk about the
network State how it works why it's so
important and how Balaji anticipates
this coming to fruition I really enjoyed
this conversation and I could have
talked to Balaji for many more hours
don't forget that these episodes are
brought to you by ftxus you can click on
the link in the description to learn
more about their offering let's get into
this episode with blushy and hope you
guys enjoy it alright everyone I'm very
excited about this uh Balaji is here the
network State I feel like I could just
turn it over to you and you could give
us a lecture but uh maybe we could just
start with this idea of
um the network State itself like how
does this happen how do we go from where
we are today to one of these being
created and actually scaled on a global
basis
okay great question so uh you know the
books at the networkstate.com and
um so I think
one one way of talking about it is first
how does this thing happen and then
second what happens after it happens
right so how does it happen well there's
a bunch of uh so first what are we even
talking about so the network State uh
you know I've got both a uh a short
informal definition then a longer
definition so the informal definition is
um a network state is a highly aligned
online community with the capacity for
Collective action that crowdfunds
territory around the world and
eventually gains diplomatic recognition
from pre-existing States now the thing
about that is a network state does not
yet exist people one of the points I
make in this is uh there's a lot of
adjacent things there's a lot of things
that are like similar to network States
in a sense but like Google is not yet a
network State you know uh Bitcoin is not
a dow is not
um they're adjacent but they're not the
same thing and the reason is that they
aren't uh there's various ways in which
they sort of fall short of the
definition for example
um Bitcoin has you know obviously it has
uh you know the reserve currency but it
doesn't have a government doesn't have a
um doesn't have land uh you know
bitcoiners you know don't agree with
each other on many things
um it doesn't have the national
Consciousness that is uh you know what
really defines a country you know even
the term by the way nation state I talk
about this a fair bit in the book you've
heard that term before uh but do you
know what the difference between the
nation and the state is no what is it
so most people don't think about that
right in fact there's a reason for that
because Nation comes from the same root
word as like natality so it's like
common birth right common descent common
ethnicity like the Japanese ha are the
Japanese nation is a group of people the
Japanese people
and then you know by the distinction is
the Japanese state is like a government
that sits over those people and uh you
know that that Japanese Nation could
have many different kinds of governments
that used to have you know the Empire
like Imperial Japan now it has like you
know liberal Democratic Japan but it's
like this very thin layer of like a
government on top of this enormous body
of people that is the nation right so
there's the nation and the state on top
of it and the reason that we don't
usually think about that distinction is
actually our language and our culture
tries to Ally the distinction because
the state you know it legitimizes itself
as a represented representative of the
nation for example when you talk about
National Security or this is happening
at the national level right or
international relations and whatnot
right much of that is really Interstate
relations when you talk about a
multinational corporation it's really
like a multi-jurisdictional corporation
because it's operating in multiple
jurisdictions and like you know just to
clarify what is a nation for example
when I mentioned the Japanese Nation uh
but the the Kurds are a nation the
catalonians are a nation right that's a
group of people with sort of a common
language and culture and history but
notice that the Kurds and the
catalonians are stateless Nations that
say groups of people that are nations
but that do not have a state
how important is having a state for a
nation like is it oh it's huge huge okay
it's huge right I mean the thing is uh
there's actually a funny quote um so
just to kind of go after this word
Nation a little bit uh you know you've
obviously heard the you know proper noun
United Nations really it could be called
more like the selected Nations or the
selected Nations that happen to have
States okay and when you think about it
that way you're like oh wow there's a
bunch of ethnic groups that are really
legitimate and have a lot of culture and
history behind them that in the game of
musical chairs that was sort of the
mapping and settling of the world they
just kind of lost out they didn't get a
chair you know the music stopped and
they didn't get a piece of land to call
their own and uh so they are stateless
Nations
um you know and uh there's a book
um called invisible countries by Joshua
Keating that talks a lot about these
kind of folks
um and there's groups like this all
around the world and there are varying
sizes you know some are small or some
are large
um
and the thing is that uh it was actually
funny like the president of Kazakhstan
recently
um he actually spoke against the concept
of self-determination
um you know why no why
he said if the principle of
self-determination is endorsed we will
go from something like 190 U.N member
states to something like 600.
okay so there's this enormous Jack in
the Box pressure for people who want
their own State and you know it would
just go like this and you just have this
enormous energy of suddenly folks who
were not able to self-govern being able
to self-govern right is this why you get
like people like the Kurds and uh
involved in so such deep conflict which
appears to be over land and kind of this
statehood that you're mentioning that's
part of it for sure it's part of it
right and you know many many conflicts
like this are over land and that seems
like impossible to solve how would you
you know fix this issue and one of the
key Concepts behind the network State
system that I'm proposing is if you know
enough history see lots of things today
that we grew up with as constants are
becoming variables right so pomp you're
born in early 80s late 70s ish or late
late 80s I just look older than that all
right okay fine fine so you are you know
basically my contemporary the 1980. um
so the uh so the thing is that the stuff
that we grew up with
um for example just take the the US
dollar right that was a constant up
until basically 2009 and suddenly it's
become a variable with Bitcoin right and
uh you know various things like you know
the US World Order or
um you know the the things that people
thought of as apolitical when they say
it's getting political suddenly there's
like factions back and forth on
something that you never even thought
there'd be a different opinion on
um that you thought was just so like
fixed that no no one would care and
that's now a point of contention right
and so as once you kind of realized this
that that order that was constant is
becoming a variable you apply that to
the nation-state system itself and you
know this has been around for so long
that if you know anything that you were
born into it's just kind of the way the
world has always been and you don't
necessarily see seek to question
especially if it stayed constant for 30
years or 40 years or 60 years or seven
years
but you know what proceeded the nation
state system so there's a a country
called San Marino uh your Italian
descent right or ever been there like do
you know San Marino ever heard of it yes
it's like it's like this tiny little
thing it's almost like a like a
duckbilled platypus like a missing link
you know between the past and the
present and San Marino you know I may be
getting the history wrong probably you
know an Italian historian right correct
me but
um when Garibaldi was unifying Italy uh
you know San Marino granted him like
refuge and in gratitude he kind of left
them out of his you know unification
thing right and most people don't know
that like you know the French Revolution
basically created France and Bismarck
created Germany and Garibaldi created
Italy and these were giant Feats of
social construction and in fact
nationalism was something that actually
in some ways came from the left at least
with the the French Revolution now it's
identified with the ripe it came from
the left as a way to make all people in
this jurisdiction equal and a lot of the
people who we think of as for example
speaking French
um I think uh gosh what's his name Eric
uh Eric hobb's mom has a stat I forget
the exact number but it's like small
double digits it was 10 or 20 or
something of the territory of France
actually spoke French what we think of
as a language French at the time of the
Revolution and a bunch of other people
spoke different dialects that got erased
by the sort of imperializing campaign of
the French Revolution to turn it all
French right now I don't know enough
about the linguistic history to know how
different those dialects were from
French itself or whether they're truly
mutually unintelligible and so on I'm
relying on Hobson's account but I've
seen similar things about the formation
of Italy the formation of Germany so
essentially what happened was that you
know there's this whole thing you can
look at called the German question on
whether
um you know Prussia and you know who is
to take the lead in a United Germany was
it going to be like Prussia or Hanover
and uh you know all of this stuff
happened well before people you know
today were paying attention or are alive
right but
um let me see I'm getting that right on
the the German question Prussia versus
Hanover right
um the best way to achieve a unification
of all our most lands uh and
um you know like little Germany versus
greater Germany right and
um the you know I may be getting some of
the details wrong but the the
fundamental point is that all of these
giant States and they're actually pretty
big right like Germany's like 80 million
people like France is like you know 60
million people like all of these giant
states were constructed over the last
few hundred years by
um guys like Bismarck like Garibaldi
um the you know you could you know the
French revolutionaries uh and you know
you can argue that Napoleon Consolidated
that Revolution and you know obviously
the American revolutionaries the Russian
revolutionaries uh you know uh folks
like Mao who unified China even India
was never a unified Nation until
basically living memory like the you
know late 40s early 50s like 1940 1950
India actually it wasn't just that they
got independence from the British there
were 562 princely states that um
got merged into India okay
I have a question about this exact uh
time period where a lot of this started
to happen is it driven by individual uh
greed and ambition there was one person
said hey I want to unify all of this
because then I can control This Land Is
there something around a piece of
technology the invention of Corporations
like why is it that we didn't have this
until a certain point in time and then
it feels like the entire world uh kind
of got unified in these almost like
subcultures or sub States uh and it
happened very sequentially and and you
know in the grand scale of things very
quickly one after the other
so you know the sovereign individual
which I think is a good book I actually
have uh one thing is uh you know the
book that I've released the network
State think of it as a V1 I actually
have you know maybe under 300 or 400
pages of content that I've got uh you
know that I wanna I wanna put in the
director's cut okay this is only 460
pages right now so it'll be like a
thousand Pages I'm actually I'm
completely serious I've got graphs I've
got charts dependencies I do not
download it at all
okay so it's very much the V1
um but one section I've got in there are
you know arguments and counter arguments
to the sovereign individual thesis
because it's not an individualities I
think is quite good but there's also
counter arguments against it which we
can digress on or double click on but
just as harm initial assist itself is
that centralization increased that is to
say
um technology favorite centralization
for several hundred years and uh you had
um you know for example like join and
die in the French and Indian War you had
the telegraph you had uh railroads you
had mass production you had mass media
um you had these gigantic militaries
that came from the centralized
bureaucracies all the stuff up until
like roughly 1950 favorite
centralization he built these Geiger
States absolutely gigantic Empires the
American Empire and the Soviet Empire
you know the Nazis the Japanese empire
all slugging it out over giant
quantities of territory because they're
huge you know Returns on scale and uh
and moreover because the communications
networks are so centralized people
couldn't argue peer-to-peer it became
very expensive to set up a a newspaper
or to get a TV license it was highly
regulated highly constrained so the
whole thing got choke pointed through
and a few people could basically control
mass of tens hundreds of millions of
people and then they just slugged it out
in these huge Wars of the 20th century
and the ideologies that they propounded
were those ideologies that could
basically script massive numbers of
people you know and and then put them
into war basically and the best of those
was Democratic capitalism relative to
you know communism and Nazism but it was
still a mass ideology that actually did
you know blow up a lot of people it was
it was you know the least bad of them I
think I think I would agree but if you
read like human smoke or or something
like that by Nicholson Baker you'll see
it actually you know had it had a lot of
negative things it's not just the
Japanese internments the gold seizures
it's you know all the stuff that FDR did
also food rules and did blah blah okay
fine so uh point is uh the sovereign
individual thesis says that centralizing
Force essentializing Technologies you
know brought that together and then
decentralization has taken it down I
think that's true I think it's also
something where
um there's both sort of left and
right-wing forces that uh you know as we
would conventionally think of them that
um happened during this time that were
aided and perhaps you know only even
feasible because of Technology but had a
feedback effect with it and there's sort
of the left egalitarianism of let us all
be citizens you know in in the nation of
France nationalism was
um egalitarian relative to the monarchy
and then later was nationalism as a
right thing which is we all need to band
together in terms of defense and
basically you know German nationalism in
part uh you know and again maybe getting
the strong maybe a historical but my
understanding is
the Napoleonic Wars in part led to the
rise of German nationalism because
people are like we need to band together
against this insane you know French
Colossus like at the time you know under
Napoleon French was France was not
considered the whatever the stranger
monkeys or whatever they were you know
the military power of Europe and Germany
was actually the one that needed to get
its act together
so so there are various forces it was it
was uh you know technology it was left
ideologies right alligations net net is
you had Returns on scale for a long time
and now we are seeing with the Advent I
think I think technology is probably the
primary driver of it we're seeing just
massive like negative Returns on scale
diseconomies of scale and the whole
thing is decentralizing is these are
like much much faster than it
centralized so it's like a centralizing
ramp up over multiple centuries and it's
like decentralizing over the span of
like one century okay so maybe 5x or 10x
is faster is this the idea of like
de-globalization is uh that's kind of
how some people try to talk about this
phenomenon but you're basically
presenting a different lens on it but
it's this idea that like we're going to
go back to a nationalistic Viewpoint and
there's less globalization
yes it's interesting uh I think uh so
deglobalization is interesting because
I'm not sure it'll happen in exactly
that way so zaihan and other guys talk
about that right and you know Zion I
think you know I I I probably agree with
him like 30 20 something like that
um very probably which discreet in other
pieces but
here's Mighty Sun like globalization
deglobalization Etc
um first is I think globalization
continues online
um but it goes in reverse offline so you
have like physical nationalism but you
have digital uh globalization and that's
actually the tension of this Century it
is the cloud versus the land
you have this Global community of
um you know remote working because on
the one hand you've got all these Trends
pushing towards total internationalism
right you have cryptocurrency you have
remote work you have starlink you have
this massive Global community of startup
entrepreneurs and folks who are more
connected than they've ever been you
know uh you have encryption which is
cross-borders
um you have uh you know you have all of
those things you have the metaverse
coming you have billions of people with
smartphones
um you have transnational companies all
of those are huge pushes on the digital
side for continued globalization and
accelerated in fact in some ways on the
other hand you have the land pushing
against that uh where various countries
various politicians want to retain their
control over their jurisdiction they
want to use the State against the
network right and so it's actually more
complicated than simply declobalization
this is a political axis of
um you know State versus Network and
what's interesting about this is is
centralization and decentralization you
can actually cut that where in some
sense the state is decentralized because
you have lots and lots of little pieces
around the world if you de-globalized on
their hand within any jurisdiction it's
centralized it's decentralized power
right conversely the network in a sense
is uh you know globally centralized
because you have a central administrator
of a Google or something like that that
goes across the whole world but it's
also in a different sense decentralized
because you can have Bitcoin or ethereum
or something like that where your
private keys are local across different
countries right so there's like an
interesting aspect of this where you can
start slicing this and I think it's more
complicated than simply the world
deglobalizes
um one other aspect of this which I
think is quite important is
um my mental model is uh a centralized
yeast in a decentralized West and then
what we want is actually a recentralized
center okay and why do I see it that way
so a centralized east to decentralized
west the sovereign individual thesis is
quite good but
um you know anything that's that's like
a huge piece of the future people often
tend to just extrapolate that Trend out
and they don't account for the Soros
concept of so-called reflexivity have
you heard about that concept you know
what that is one of the key concepts of
Finance yes
it was he okay why don't you why don't
you explain it then yeah the whole idea
basically is uh the further that things
can uh move in One Direction uh they
basically can reflexively move back uh
in the other direction just as fast
um and there's a uh balance I think in
human psychology becomes a huge
component uh of that balance and kind of
the reaction there's a reaction to every
action uh in some way and especially in
financial assets where uh right when
people are ready to sell to walk away to
give up uh that's usually the time where
uh there's a snapback if you will of uh
of those assets
that's right and you know the thing is
of course sometimes things really just
do go to zero sometimes things
um you know actually like Venture
capitals model if you think about it is
buy the all-time high and hope it goes
higher right that that's what it is to
be a series a or series B investor
you're basically in a sense buying the
all-time high of that stock yes and then
hoping it's it goes even higher and you
can make money that way frankly you can
but um it is it is something which is uh
it's certainly atypical relative how a
hedge fund person will think about it
the reason I just bring up reflexivity
is
um especially when it's a human Trend it
may not go to Infinity right the fact
that it's rising often arouses
bandwagoning against that Trend right
and so with respect to the sovereign
individual I think there's at least
three counter Trends and those are
um you know what I call the individual
Sovereign uh The Sovereign Collective
and the autonomous robot okay so the
individual Sovereign is like somebody
like Xi Jinping or Putin or somebody you
know Elon somebody like that who has
like enough influence over the future
that they can turn you know even if the
trend is towards uh you know
decentralization it's also Trend towards
individual empowerment and someone like
physician ping has pushed the entire
country towards centralization of a
billion people right so paradoxically
the sovereign individual talks about how
individuals get super empowered and
here's a super empowered individual who
is pushing the disempowerment of other
individuals which is very meta okay
um
so that's like you know the individual
Sovereign is a flying the agreement the
second is The Sovereign Collective
because I think it's challenging for I
do think that the size of groups that
you need to get something done reduces
but it doesn't like
um it doesn't mean that you don't need
other people for anything it just means
it gets smaller
um you can do more things with autonomy
you you can have things like Minecraft
or Bitcoin with like one person or
Instagram and WhatsApp with double digit
numbers of people that's all true and I
do think the size of groups you know
shrinks and you have many more CEOs and
many more smaller companies and so on
we're already seeing something like us
many smaller countries as well but that
doesn't mean it goes to like I think
everybody's just one person or even that
there's a group of people that are just
like one person I think people want
community and so on so I think the
Sovereign Collective is another
important counterweight to that because
um you know the the state will push back
on you if you're just an individual on
your own you represent no constituency
the smallest minority is is one person I
think is like Ryan would say and that's
actually why a prag a pragmatist uh
realizes hey if I can group with other
people I can probably achieve objectives
Maybe by sacrificing some individual
autonomy but
um I think the Sovereign Collective is
going to be a big thing is a big thing
right and that's crowdfunding that is uh
you know Facebook groups that is
um signal but it's also a big part of
the Network's hit and the third is the
autonomous robot because a lot of the
logic of Bitcoin and of the sovereign
individual is well
um you know the the 20th century was
about these gigantic Wars where you know
the states could seize all the money and
they could seize the money and they
could use that for these you know planes
and tanks and kill each other and uh you
know they could also uh inflate the
currency and all of that goes away when
you have cryptocurrency right you've
heard you've heard this thesis I have
okay along these lines one key piece I
think that people uh don't quite yet
understand okay uh but but just to kind
of hit home so in the physical world
obviously if you have the most powerful
offense you are the you know military
dominant uh um kind of nation-state
group Etc uh when you push up into the
Digital World
um there's still a lot of people who say
hey Adams matter right it's not all just
bits obviously if somebody comes and
takes your computer puts you in jail
whatever uh that that's a a problem but
there is this concept of like actually
in the cyber world defense the strongest
defense means that you are more powerful
how do you evaluate offense First
Defense in the physical world and then
does that change the evaluation of the
digital world
yeah so I think the way I kind of
connected to is I've got a section in
the book called rubber hoses don't scale
okay so you know people always say oh
the rubber hose attack haha LOL you're
just some moronic crypto guy who doesn't
understand that I can find and beat you
up and take your private keys and then
my counter argument against that is okay
but can you do so at a profit what I
mean by that is uh the state is not you
know doesn't have infinite resources it
needs to first take that Bitcoin address
or whatever address and it has to map it
to a physical person and then find that
person's current location and then have
you know the the search warrant or
whatever that is valid in that
jurisdiction because they might be in
you know whatever country uh they have
to be able to then land the SWAT team
they have to go kick in the door they
have to find that guy's private key and
they have to hope it's got enough money
to pay for that entire process and they
need to repeat that over and over again
right and if that you know like a SWAT
team is actually kind of expensive it
costs I don't know how many but like
certainly tens of thousands of dollars
and um you better hope that like that
coercive seizure is making you more
money than it's costing you
um and uh that it's not resulting in
film that will actually make a lot of
people think okay screw these military
eyes police abolish the police you know
defund the police you know resist the
police whatever whatever right and uh
because if you do use Force sometimes
the use of force is really complicated
because often the use of force if it's
considered illegitimate can arouse
significant backlash that is more you
know just stupid to use Force you know
um and so that's why like that's why
rubber bullets exist that's why nuclear
bombs just didn't grow to Infinity why
did you know for example a while back
there's this guy uh Eric swalvo he he's
like uh talking about how the US
government has nukes and so therefore
nobody can fight back against it do you
remember remember this post or tweet for
a few years I don't but that sounds like
something that would be on the internet
as an argument and did pass from reality
yeah yeah yeah so so the reason that's
actually a really bad argument is
if you actually
um think about like the point is not to
just like randomly kill lots of people
if you nuked just to take this stupid
thought experiment but it's actually
useful as a thought experiment in this
sense if you actually went and like
nuked Dallas or something like that
you'd kill lots of uh his tribe as well
right and it's not a surgical tool
because it's not surgical it can't
actually be deployed because his goal is
to try and bring the other tribe to heal
and that means you know basically going
and killing or you know attacking or
censoring or de-platforming their guys
without hitting his own guys and so in
fractal America where if you look at the
map it's all these red and blue cheek by
jowl one side can't really like going
strafe and bomb the other side because
in physical space they're so cheap by
jowl that anything is going to hit the
other person right and so that won't get
political support from that side and so
instead the Warfare is online you know
it is it's very different than the 1860s
in the 1860s you had these two tribes
and they weren't just ideologically
separated but they're geographically
separated North and South were separated
right you can look at the map whereas uh
here let me actually let me show you
some visuals so maybe you guys can
the first is that's a map of blue and
gray how they're separated in 1861 and
if you go to the second one
that's how it looks in 2016. so
physically there's no way you can invade
or bomb the swab will cheat on nuking
nuking just doesn't work you're killing
too many of your own guys whatever tribe
you're in and then you go to the third
in the digital space they're separated
that is actually now that looks like the
1861 map again and that's why it's so
insane online because you have you know
this this front of two groups that are
ideologically separated but because the
physical space is so fractal any kind of
conflict is going to look like you know
a network War Network as opposed to 20th
century or 1900 you know 1800s were
um so what does that mean one of the
things that I think is really
interesting about this is
um when I think of just from personal
experience right so in Iraq in 2005
through like 2010 there's a program
called sons of Iraq and what they
essentially did was uh it was partially
in the analog world of we need physical
soldiers we need people to uh kind of
Patrol their local communities Etc but
there was also a psychological aspect of
it which is you are an Iraqi citizen you
probably have some sort of military
experience or you have some sort of uh
um you know combat training or whatever
it is and we as the United States said
to these individuals we cannot Patrol
your whole country we cannot uh be in
every single local community you have to
take responsibility you have to have
pride in your country you have to have a
feeling of um kind of responsibility for
your local community and so what we're
going to do is we're going to try to
empower you we're going to empower you
in the analog world but in some ways
that program was never recognized for
the psychological component of trying to
say hey if you don't want these people
who you deem to be bad in your local
community you as the sons of Iraq you
are responsible for
um you know setting up checkpoints and
keeping people out of your communities
Etc and we as the United States will
help now people will argue over the
efficacy of the program [ __ ] was trying
to combine the analog we will give you
weapons we will give you training we
will you know do all these things kind
of in the physical world but also
psychologically there had to be a kind
of a step function change if you will in
the way that people thought about uh
their responsibility or their
interaction in their communities and you
know the proponents of this program
would argue it was the turning point
right it literally changed the kind of
Battlefield because now all of a sudden
you were able to multiply the number of
soldiers and it goes back to this idea
of they weren't necessarily enemies
coming at you right because they were
kind of uh more so uh agnostic and just
saying hey like I just want to live my
life I'm not on either side uh but the
United States was able to use these
individuals to then uh be helpful for
their cause which you know I I think is
a past example but now you're making the
argument that that's going to happen on
the digital front not just in the
physical world we understand kind of
what has happened in history right in
terms of how we've kind of got here some
people understand better than others but
where do we go from here in terms of
what these Network States like what do
you anticipate will happen
sure okay so
fundamentally what we're having is
situation where because in part of the
internet but also because of trends that
predate the internet is broader
decentralization thing you have people
in physical jurisdictions where that
latent difference
is now popping up right America is no
longer really just a it's not a nation
state it's a minimum a bi-national state
right because you've got red and blue
but you've also got lots of sub
ethnicities and so on under that we're
not used to thinking of red and blue as
ethnicities but if you look at marriage
patterns for example people will now
marry outside their race it's actually
you know very very common
um at least as expressed pollsters but
they won't marry outside their party
okay Democrats won't marry Democrats and
Republicans increasingly Or democrats
will only marry Democrats and
Republicans increasingly will only marry
Republicans that's been trending way up
and the thing is in a generation that
kind of ideology becomes biology it
becomes at a minimum Democrat Republican
becomes like you know Protestant
Catholic or Sunni and Shiite
right the ideology becomes a biology if
you're only going and finding a spouse
within that group and telling yourself
the only matters in that group and so on
right so that happens very fast and then
that becomes like ethnic right and that
becomes like I shouldn't say intractable
because it can be it can be solved but
it's difficult harder to solve right
it's more it's not really about policy
it's tribe versus tribe
and so the thing is that that is uh like
happening in a lot of places worldwide
and a lot of people don't realize that
uh you know they don't know Garibaldi
they don't know Bismarck they don't know
what happened with the French Revolution
they don't realize like how much
centralized Force
in different ways and and propaganda
okay the combination of both right and
left in that sense you know
um was required to like flatten out
these huge regions and centralize them
under certain things they kind of think
that's the way the world always was
there's an enormous amount of force an
enormous amount of propaganda that
levels all of that out that kind of
erased all these other dialects in favor
of official French or you know wiped out
all these other small jurisdictions in
favor of what we now know as Italy right
and that was obviously cataclysmic in
some ways but it also resulted in what
we think of as a modern world
and now we're getting I think the V3
right so I mentioned San Marino and it's
like this
um it's like this duckbilled platypus
it's like this Missing Link where if you
look at the history of San Marino
um it actually shows why we exited the
city state age and went to the nation
state age and a big thing by the way is
city state nation state Network state is
a progression that's sort of similar to
like gold
um you know Fiat or dollars and digital
gold you know why I say that should I
explain that explain
so the key thing is that like Bitcoin is
is a V3
we talk about is digital gold and it has
some of the properties of gold like the
immutability and so on in fact it
improves on some of those properties the
custodial aspect and whatnot but
actually and we sort of take this for
granted has many of the same properties
as Fiat you can send it electronically
you can represent it on a screen you can
write programs with it all that type of
stuff right and if it didn't have those
properties it wouldn't really be a
contender it would it would not be it's
not a throwback it's not a V1 it's a V3
that combines aspects of both V1 and V2
and the idea there is if it only had the
aspects of V1 in a digital form uh you
would either Miss parts of V2 which
wouldn't make it competitive or people
would uh view it as inferior uh given
that they could send it digitally uh
Fiat but if Bitcoin was somehow physical
in nature or something then obviously it
wouldn't work in this digital world yeah
so well so let's say it was just V1
let's say it's basically like you know
by the way I have nothing against Peter
Schiff
um
I respect him for calling the you know
mortgage Christ and so on but he does
like to troll Bitcoin okay fine so let's
say it's gold it's Peter schiff's you
know beloved thing and actually by the
way gold may may have its own little
boom lit or what have you okay but
um you know the thing about gold is gold
was defeated by the state right
executive order 6102 gold was seized
gold is something that you can detect
with metal detectors gold is something
that is very heavy to transport gold is
something where you can't easily like
chip off a flake and just use it at
Starbucks right gold is not a very
easily negotiable instrument
um it has lower liquidity than BTC which
is actually quite liquid you know and uh
so because of that uh like you know is
is Bitcoin as liquid as as Fiat and can
you can you can you
um pay with it as easily as you can a
dollar not really because of Transit you
know there's various various constraints
on that
um like there's transaction limits and
block size and all that stuff yes you
can use lightning and but having those
workarounds I agree but point is that
like uh gold V1 if you just tried V1 you
wouldn't get that far because literally
physical blocks of gold are hard to
actually pay with you can use them as
emergency storage mechanisms but they're
hard to transport they're heavy
um you know if you wanted to transport a
million dollars a gold don't know many
how many pounds that is off top of my
head but it would probably be a fairly
large amount of of weight to carry right
so V1 has a lot of downsides
which is why people go with V2 and so
before Bitcoin when people would just
sort of be like we need gold we need to
go back to sound money and so on it's
just it was like uh it was directionally
accurate in some ways you know there's
there's a a solid critique in some ways
of the problems of the present but there
wasn't like the practicality of how does
this new thing
um account for the fact that the
president beat the past
if you have you know the president beat
the past so whatever he propose is the
future it needs to be able to beat the
president it's almost like combining in
some ways the policies of V1 right or
kind of the structure of V1 but the
technology of V2 yeah
exactly the specific Fusion May differ
in different domains but the V3 has to
be kind of better than both right
um and often you know so I'll give
several examples of this and then let me
talk about the network chain itself so
um you know you have physical paper and
then you have
um
a scan document like a scanner then you
have like a digitally native file which
never even exists in the physical world
right or you have you know a different
way you have a paper currency then you
have like
um a bank interface like PayPal or
that's really that's a layer on top of a
bank interest but you see your dollars
in the bank of trees then you have
cryptocurrency which is natively digital
or you have
um you know you have a uh movie that you
see offline and then you have like a
Netflix you know streaming thing where
you know you've got a film that's in
Hollywood then you have internet native
content that was authored on the
internet and it's not like streaming
from some like Hollywood library right
and you can kind of think a lot of
things have this progression where this
like physical there's a physical digital
hybrid like a scanned version then
there's a purely digital version
and so
um you know so that's like that's a
progression just within the internet if
we take a longer time frame we say city
state nation state Network State the
reason that city-states the V1 were
beaten by nation states is that nation
states had scale right that's why San
Marino is the structural plebus and you
should see it's like they just scooped
up all of these small principalities
into this huge thing because it had
massive scale and the problem with
people who are like you know go back to
city-states or you know uh you know I
want my small liberal land like my sea
land my small country and so and so
forth it's sort of like the appeal to
Gold where I understand why they want it
you know hey let's have lots of small
governments and so on but those small
governments the past was beaten by the
present for a reason the president has
scale those Nation seats have scale they
have offensive capabilities city-states
were defeated by nation states Network
States though are a V3 in my view and
why because
they combine some of the aspects of both
nation and city-states so they have the
scale or potential scale of a
nation-state since in theory you could
have an international Network
um that had uh you know millions of
members in fact take a look at uh I've
got a little GIF here because you know
sometimes a
picture what you're basically what
you're basically talking about here it's
it's fascinating because even if you
look at something uh across Industries
it really is the analog world was a game
of scale and so naturally people would
push into the digital realm and if you
take I don't know books right there's
physical bookstores that usually were
Mom and Pops then there got scale by
then going to the chains of the Barnes
and Nobles whatever then Amazon came
along and said hey we have a digital
version that gives us more scale and
then eventually what people realized is
like we don't even have to create the
actual physical book we can just
literally have a digital file and so you
can kind of see this progression across
industry after industry after industry
and whoever basically gets to the the
end State the fastest uh and does it in
a sustainable way they tend to have the
advantage it appears you know over the
long run taking a look at this right
let's keep this GIF on Loop for a second
so this probably tells the story like in
a few you know frames faster than I
could in words so this is an example of
a hypothetical medical Network state
that starts with one person in Tokyo
okay and they recruit other people and
they connect them together and notice in
the top right their crowdfunding
territory square meters of territory
around the world to live together and
how are they doing it in the top middle
the annual income is how much they're
booking in you know let's say approval
it could be crypto income eventually or
partially crypto income but they
basically have some proof of income in
the middle right
and one of the things I point out in the
book is that the census uh was actually
did you know the census is part of the
US Constitution like the post office I
did not know
so it's actually you know it's actually
something that they thought of as
actually being very important from the
very beginning they needed information
about their young Republic in order to
do something it was a huge undertaking
which is why the census only done every
10 years you know because you have to
take all this paper and you know I don't
know if you've ever seen what a million
piece of paper looks like but it's a lot
of piece of paper right and you didn't
have Excel you had to add up all of that
by hand every cross tab had to be in my
hand just imagine the warehouse and how
people had to set it up right so now our
census you know you can do something not
a million people every 10 years but like
Facebook in theory could compute and
does actually have a real-time census on
three billion people in a second okay so
that's like several orders of magnitude
you know if you go just think it out
right 3650 days is 10 years and then
you're doing that not in an hour but in
a second that is like you know six or
seven orders of magnitude improved in
terms of your speed to go from 10 years
to to one second right and um
the the point about that is
now the problem is not the speed of the
computation but the reliability of it
okay how do you know before it was
something where okay is the US
government going to fake their census
you know okay maybe maybe you trust them
maybe you wouldn't but now anybody can
put whatever number they want online so
this census for a network State you're
going to need a lot of the proof of X
proof of Y techniques we've talked about
like proof of human proof of income
proof of real estate all those things
actually the cryptographic proof that
that transaction occurred with many
different overlapping points of evidence
any one of which could be fallacious but
combined together you get statistical
inference right you have some estimate
of you know how probable is it that this
number is correct right it's not going
to be deterministic it's going to be
Cisco even Bitcoin for example you know
the um the calculation that Satoshi put
in the white paper is the statistical
calculation of You Know How likely it is
that uh you know you're going to have
finality after like six blocks
and so you do this ciscal calculation
you're like how reliable are these uh
population and income and uh real estate
Footprints and if that census is
reliable if you have managed to build a
community that's like this and there's
more details that I talk about in the
book but if you if you can build
something at the scale of all these
people who think of themselves as being
part of the same nation and who actually
crowdfund territory and live together in
it if you notice the buildings if you go
bring the put the gift back on screen
um those uh the buildings on the left
hand side sort of increase in complexity
so you know right the footprint starts
getting larger in each of these cities
right it starts as like just one guy in
his house and eventually it becomes
cul-de-sacs and ranches and small towns
and maybe even small cities and they're
all networked together and when I say
they're all networked together
um well you know the the Advent of
augmented reality glasses which I talk
about coming that's like the most
predictable next thing in Tech you know
like the iPhone was this conversion
device our glasses that you tap and then
just boom you can just see ghosts from
the internet in in real life those are
going to make it much easier to Network
all of these different physical regions
together into something that feels like
the same country right let me ask you a
question about this because I think the
number one critique I was trying to
think of like what are the biggest
critiques I've heard of uh people saying
around this network uh State thesis and
the number one thing that uh I've seen
people talking about is okay
theoretically this makes a ton of sense
but you still have to have the physical
location whether it's a building whether
it's land whether it's whatever how do
those individuals in that building or
land defend themselves from the existing
nation-state structure so if you
participate in a network State how does
that interface with the nation state and
do nation states view this as a threat
or abrasive or do they embrace it like
like how do you think about those two uh
or maybe the line between the nation
state and Network State blurring in the
physical world where the network State
still needs physical space
great question so actually I've got a
whole section on this that I will add
and then tweet out called uh diplomatic
relations
right between because I talk about
diplomatic recognition as this core part
of it right so diplomatic relations
between Network States and nation states
is actually you know what's similar to
it's similar to the crypto Fiat
interface
because it's like the interface between
cryptocurrency Bitcoin and fiat currency
the US dollar
um was not something that actually uh to
my knowledge at least Satoshi wrote
about originally he sort of thought that
the crypto economy could bootstrap
itself kind of completely on its own he
had like the poker thing that was built
into the app at the beginning right but
it turned out that the BTC USD interface
that exchange rate once that exchange
rate occurred right
um and you could argue it occurred
implicitly with the the pizza day
transaction right but the exchange rate
between BTC and USD that is you know
like future historians will see that as
something that almost looks like it went
zero to one right like that it looks
infinite or like it like it just goes
vertical because it's over it's very
fast over a short period of time but
while we're living through it as you
know it has ups and downs and it
retraces and so on and so forth
um before you know like maybe you'll go
to Infinity I don't we'll see okay but
the thing is that um ah so this this
image by the way here this shows a
visual of what I'm talking about where
if you scroll down right that's that's
Apple's AR kit which is a preview of
what you'll see with your AR glasses so
if you hold a certain nft you see a
glowing sigil you're part of this secret
society this Freemasons or or what have
you and all the people who have that nft
can see that sigil and nobody who
doesn't can right and uh
that means that you you have a layer
over the world where citizenship becomes
like single sign-on you know you have a
private key you have an nft that is your
digital passport and you can literally
see aspects of the world that others
can't it's like your physical login
right and uh so you can start to see how
with something like that you can take
all these territories around the world
and you know brand is uh it's kind of an
unfortunate term because it seems very
corporate but think about if you walk
into the Google offices anywhere in the
world they're basically very similar you
know they're meant to be similar it's
got the Google logo maybe there's like a
little ethnic touch for that country
like the Google doodle but they're
fundamentally very similar
and that's intentional it's like a
little piece of Google a slice of Google
around the world but that's within the
context of commercial real estate these
are all fundamentally commercial
buildings office space what if you
extended that to residential real estate
and Industrial and you had all those
linked together and it wasn't a company
but a community that owned them right
that you could do and then The Branding
would be more like you have a bunch of
chinatowns for example or little indias
around the world but they're networked
together and now you actually start
having something which nothing I'm
describing is like technically
infeasible you know all these little
subroutines exist right chinatowns exist
little Indies exist Google exists single
silent exists all those pieces exist
right what I'm kind of talking about is
the system integration and bringing them
together into this uh you know community
that is physically distributed but
digitally connected in one place and one
way of thinking about this by the way is
if you live in Hawaii
many people I mean they think of
themselves as part of the same country
as somebody who lives in New York
okay they're not driving to New York
um in fact they probably don't go off
the island of Hawaii that frequently so
that gift that I just showed is actually
not that different from how people live
already
you know they like the you don't need
that much contiguous space in the middle
it's not fly over country it is I'm
probably there's probably some clever
one-liner you could have but it's like
teleport over a country you know because
you're just setting the packets over you
know
um
and so these other regions are as you
know as long as your individual pockets
are large enough
um and that depends you know a person in
just like one place on their own could
kind of think of themselves as like a
just like an American expat living
overseas thinks themselves as American
even if they're surrounded by a lot of
foreign Nationals right like a building
that had just one person from a network
state that person would LARP themselves
into thinking of themselves as part of
this larger community and once it gets
to on the order of a hundred thousand to
a million people if and when it gets
there it's actually not that
unreasonable a lark and the reason for
that is that most countries are small
countries actually here's another
graphic from the beginning of the book
that I'll show you
I mean in some way what you're
describing there are
um crumbs of it already occurring uh
Google is a good example right in terms
of like you think of yourself as uh I
adhere to this uh Community which
happens to be a for-profit company
there's physical space uh there's a
single sign-on to get into the the
internal uh systems uh but you also can
kind of extrapolate that out and you see
uh people doing this in a variety of
different ways
um it's just no one's done it from an
actual nation-state you know
transitioning to a network state if you
will
right and so if you take a look for
example at this uh just here's a way to
calibrate like the the reasonableness of
this if you go and look at this uh link
that I just pasted in and scroll all the
way down to the bottom
most countries are small countries
only 14 countries are 100 million person
countries
and the reason that that is
counter-intuitive is probably most
people live in big countries but most
countries are small countries right and
so the thing about that is most the
countries that the United Nations
are like you know like sub one uh sub 10
million right and as you know we can
build social networks of that scale you
know I mean it's not trivial to build uh
uh you know a 10 million person social
network but it's definitely doable and
there's there's definitely a lot of
people who have built
um you know 100K 1 million person
followings online like you and I are I
think are at that level that's not
that's not like that exceptional right
and so now of course there's a huge
difference between
like clicking a button and following
somebody versus
um actually going and having a much
higher level of commitment to think of
yourself as part of a country but in
terms of the horizontal scale we're
there right look we've got massive
horizontal scale for like joining
Facebook and now you know the next level
up from that from spending hours and
hours a day on something which is
actually a pretty big commitment by the
way I should say
um The Next Step Up from spending hours
a day on a social network is starting to
invest huge chunks of your net worth
like even one percent of your net worth
are considered a huge chunk into a
cryptocurrency and so we may have
billions of people spending hours on
social media we have hundreds of
millions of people putting big chunks of
their net worth into cryptocurrency and
so the next question is will we have
some significant fraction of people
putting their lives into a crypto
country
when you think when you think of this
right so use me as an example I live in
the United States of America many people
would say uh it's a great place to live
uh people from all over the world want
to constantly come here there's the
American dream there's democracy there's
capitalism there's all these kind of
unique blend of things
um and let's say that that's on one end
of the spectrum then there's going to be
individuals who uh are in a place where
they're trying to leave right and they
have a unique blend of uh both
advantages and disadvantages as to why
somebody may want to stay or leave in
that country but if you put that
Spectrum out like what changes for
somebody in a western developed Nation
if they want to kind of uh transition
into one of these crypto States and what
changes for the individual who is not in
a western developed Nation but wants to
transition into a crypto State like do
they end up in the same place they just
came from two different uh kind of
starting questions
it's a good question so the thing is
uh well so the way there's a lot of
things I can say there so the first is
uh the US is becoming less attractive as
a destination for you know so-called
High net worth individuals it's down
about 86 since 2019 Henley Global has a
report on this they're also leaving
China because you know it's like the
common Prosperity Doctrine over there
they've cracked down and
um Jack Ma and all the tech Founders and
so on they're leaving Russia obviously
that's got the massive Global outflix
they're leaving India though they're
getting replenished within India by like
new Founders but it's um I think it's
like Net Zero but where they're going
they're going to small countries and
um this is being a trend that's been
going on for some time and I think so
it's not you know the other thing is
also like the concept of the developed
world and the developing world this is
something which I think is it's now
probably worth deconstructing that
um and the reason is that the way I talk
about it is the uh ascending world
ending world or the ascending class in
the descending class that's the
individual version of it so the reason I
say that is uh you know so here is it's
a you know do I want to call this an
unfair comparison I think it's
um
it's partially Fair uh but take a look
at this
um
this is a underrated Twitter account by
the way underrated account yeah so so
look at her comment right so at first
glance I thought this was India right
now here's the thing a lot of people
jumped jumped on her for that right and
the thing is India you know there's
parts of India that did look like that
that do look like that but then if you
go forward here is here are some of the
new Indian train stations like that's
clean and that's not it's not unreal
that's like a random translation that
people use go to the next one right like
the thing is I'm not saying that all of
India looks like this and so on but
parts of India do and parts of America
now look like the previous thing and so
the the distributions that were totally
disjoint you know in the 80s uh that
were basically like the richest Indian
was poorer than the poorest American
those are you know those are now like
converging right or is it you know an
equilibrium is found where like
um I I don't really know how else to
describe it other than like the United
States AIDS uh was on this epic rise at
some point it just can't keep going up
higher and higher because people get
complacent people get comfortable uh and
so naturally you would expect decline at
some point these other countries now are
the US you know 100 years ago 200 years
ago they're now on ascent and so you get
that crossover point where the US
doesn't keep improving and growing these
other countries catch up and then you
actually get the reverse like is there a
point in the future where India is you
know the new us and America is the old
India
yeah so right so basically when I when I
talk think about India by the way I'm
I'm only moderately bullish on India as
a country but I'm very bullish on
Indians as a network yes like around the
world uh including India is within India
but basically Indians in general are
just like leveling up and they're
they're having an impact on the world I
mean it's like they're on every tech
company I mean they run like every major
tech company right or at least 60 of the
top ones yeah and this is well I mean
they've done very well there and they've
also you know Indians have done well in
media and other places and this is this
is this huge new phenomenon where
um I think you know so one way of
thinking about it is if you look around
your room and you're like okay how much
of this physical world was made by you
know effectively Chinese people and
factories right or you know Chinese
entrepreneurs I think you're going to
see over the next 10 years a very large
fraction of the digital world will be
made directly or indirectly by Indians
interesting okay so like an interesting
kind of way of thinking about it right
and uh that's that's obviously like at
the CEO level and so on but I think an
under underrated thing is uh micro work
you know Outsourcing and like you know
machine learning labeling of like cat
and dog you know the digital assembly
line the new the digital blue collar on
Android phones for cryptocurrency but
basically what we're doing it earned
that like you know 10 100 a thousand a
million x bigger
that is going to be a big thing
um where you just open up your phone and
you can do micro work anywhere for
cryptocurrency like a Twitter feed right
and uh I think a lot of that is going to
happen in India because it just kind of
fits how people just you know think
about things there right they're willing
to do these sort of you know drudge type
tasks they've just got Android phones
they've got information but like you
know a dollar a day is still like a big
deal for people there so they will
actually do a good job for something
like that and and also I think this is a
part that's not appreciated
um you know my my friend uh Akshay who
actually you know I think he coined the
serum is basically like um Indians used
to need the H-1B visa but now they have
the tcpip Visa okay so it has this
podcast pretty good that's pretty good
right yeah that's pretty good and the
thing is like h1bp says you know they're
they they're down and up and you know it
seems like down and harder to get
recently but the thing is now you have
uh you know this these graphs again this
is stuff that hasn't really been
reported in the US but if you look at
the
um adoption of you know 4G or 5G rather
um this is this is something which is
just really kind of not on people's
Radars you know while the US was kind of
fighting this domestic Civil War during
the Trump years and all attention was on
the domestic kind of thing almost a
billion people got online in India from
2017 to 2021 and that's continuing right
so what that means is all those folks
are lurking in the comments section
they're all reading right and so a good
chunk of your upvotes are Indian a good
chunk of your readers and listeners are
going to be and in fact most the English
internet is going to soon be Indian
because one of the one of the best
examples I have of this is in uh 2015 or
2016
um I went to India I did like a two-week
um trip and went to multiple cities and
I kept meeting entrepreneurs and uh
they'd come up to me and they'd say you
know hey we've built X product uh we
have a hundred thousand users I remember
being like holy [ __ ] like 100 000 users
and after like the ninth or tenth time I
turned to somebody who was there and I
was like how the hell are these people
so good at growth and he was like no no
no like a hundred thousand users in
India is like 5 000 in the United States
right he's like it's just a bigger
country or whatever and so I remember
like that was one of these things where
I was like oh literally the scale of the
opportunity just to get people in your
local economy onto these products is
going to be massive imagine if they're
then able to scale them globally like
they are just used to building for scale
and getting users at a in a way that is
uh probably more difficult in the United
States and so it was just like this one
little thing that just stuck out to me
of like man this is so different than uh
kind of the United States and the way
that we think about you know consumer
products and growth
right and and the thing is that
basically the integration of India with
the global economy via the Internet is a
massive pro-globalization Force as per
going back to our earlier thing like
there's a billion people who really
really really really
want to work online for money and are
willing to do so and can do art and
computer programming and social media
and blah blah blah like lots and lots of
white-collar digital labor kinds of jobs
um they don't need an H1B Visa anymore
and they're culturally acclimated so you
know they they may speak with an accent
but they kind of know all the memes
right they're they're fluent in the
means they've been growing up with the
same memes they've been lurking for the
last five years and kind of learning all
that stuff so uh you know the first time
I realized this was actually in the
early 2010s when I I taught this huge
online course massively open online
course actually when the first um uh
first I think courses on big coin uh
here let me show you this I'm sure most
people even know about this
um but in 2013 when Bitcoin was at
double digits uh I taught this course
and actually hit 250 000 people
worldwide so yeah this is 2013 right
building so in 250 000 people you know
when Bitcoin was at like 10 bucks or
something it's like double digits like I
think it was 60 bucks or something at
that time
um
so
the point being that uh what I realized
with that course is that the internet
was to America as America was the UK
it is like the more Global the more
um like internationalist like you know
the UK had all these Innovations like
um obviously common law like all
Englishmen are equal and you know many
civilizational Innovations and then the
US leveled up and it said hey you know
we're actually going to have a written
Constitution and it's not just all
Englishmen are equal but all Europeans
can come and immigrate and so on and
um you know that built this amazing
country and then you know the next level
I think is to go from common law to
Constitution to uh you know
cryptocurrency or to a Smart contract
where it's not just like written law
with some judge who could enforce it you
know as they see fit but something where
there's a compiler that's enforcing it
there's a there's a chain that's
enforcing you that's actually more
um more difficult to to abuse and it's
more impartial a computer enforcing the
law
and it's also something which is not
just limited to those people who can get
a Visa in or something but it is anybody
with an internet connection which is
basically everybody we've enfranchised
billions of people the phone is the next
franchise in a real sense because you've
given all these people who didn't have a
voice a voice you're giving them all a
you know a way to to make money online
to build things and uh when you started
putting all of that together you're like
okay like the internet is to you know
the Americas it's like this this new New
World
um like what the new world was for the
Europeans and it is uh it is something
that I don't think people have realized
its full potential and how large it is
yet as much as we talk about it we still
haven't really conceptualized as such
because you know the new world was seen
uh but for many years by the European
powers as just being the place for them
to go and send boats and of course you
know obviously the Native Americans and
South Americans buy-ins because you know
I actually talk about that in the book
like
um there was a lot of warfare and uh you
know this different ways that one can
can think about that but the internet is
different where there's nobody on the
other side it's like you know there's
nobody who's sitting on that server
before you it's a piece of just bare
digital territory so
people think of it as just a place that
uh America or Europe or India or China
or what have you is just going to quote
settle and build American tech companies
or Chinese tournaments but over time I
think it takes on a logic of its own and
has its own internet native nationalism
where things like keto for example or
CrossFit or or Bitcoin
um are internet native things that are
in a sense genuinely International
because they cut across all
International boundaries and will
eventually be able to acquire territory
and form new nations of their own
um and that's a big part of what the
book is about well it's um the
adjustable Market is much bigger I also
think uh a lot about you and I have
talked about media but you know a bunch
of times but I think there's many
Industries where
um I call it like the uh the boardroom
expansion plan which is like I built a
company in the United States and I you
know work really hard for three or four
years and then at some point I sit down
with the board and I say okay board I
think now is time for international
expansion we all debate should we pick
like let's go to England right or let's
go to you know Mexico or like wherever
we want to go and it's like this very
kind of methodical you know Global
expansion plan and some of that's
because you know if you're doing
manufacturing or supply chain related
things there's a physical yeah but with
regulation certifications yeah but we've
even seen this with just tech companies
right I mean there was a big deal when
like Airbnb said hey we are now are
going to go and go into a certain
geography and I think what has happened
now uh is just like people turn it on
it's a global you know effort uh and
look I was at Facebook when uh
internet.org was a a big focus of uh the
business they're trying to bring
internet and the Joko is you know kind
of was like Hey we're running out of
people on Facebook so like let's go get
more people on the internet to get them
on Facebook uh and there probably was
some hint of truth to it but but I do
think that most of the effort was
genuine and like giving people internet
accesses is a net
Google at the same time was flying you
know hot air balloons and yeah doing all
the stuff but if you fast forward now
and you say like those internet
companies are going to actually lose
that internet race to starlink and
SpaceX and it was you know it was
somebody who started in a completely
different industry realized I have an
advantage now I'm going to be able to
put this satellite constellation out
there and like how impactful will
starlink be to getting more people on
the internet which then leads to more
economic productivity in this digital
world like you can just see the pieces
starting to come together and sure there
could be external shock or kind of
something catastrophic that drastically
slowed internet adoption or you know
economic productivity on the internet
but like that's pretty hard to see right
now it the writing's on the wall it
seems and we're only headed in One
Direction which is more people on the
internet more people coordinating and
doing economic Commerce there and so
naturally you would think that that's
where kind of power influence wealth Etc
all gravitates as well if that's what
people spend all their time doing
yeah you know I want to I want a word
that's like like disenfranchised but for
taking away Internet it's like
dis-intronetized or something like that
I could probably come up with something
because all these folks who have now
gotten their phones have gotten their
laptops who've gotten their voices and
and you know their crypto and so on and
so forth States will want to take that
away and that's actually why you're
seeing this push in the US and in the
CCP for censorship for crackdowns for
de-platforming for demonetization for
you know I get disinformation all that
stuff is an attempt to kind of shove the
genie back into the bottle to take away
speech from people and so and so forth
and to kind of stop this internet thing
from from getting somewhere and you know
I'm not saying those will be completely
necessarily failed I actually
unfortunately think it might it might
actually work the so-called counter
decentralization could work in China but
I don't think it's going to work in the
West
and actually
um you know to your question will it get
like stopped or would have you uh do you
draw my scenario for kind of like my
okay here's my here's my base case model
and one thing I want to say about the
book I'm going to actually edit it to
kind of make it you know more obvious
the way I think about it is it's set up
as problem and solution okay so the
problem is
uh based on kind of my world view which
is uh you know if you take my reading of
past present or future I think we're
headed for American Anarchy and Chinese
control that is to say that the us is
going to be uh potentially falling into
some conflict between uh wokes and
Bitcoin maximalists
um who we could talk about or basically
I think I think that is sort of where
things are headed and uh I think that um
so that's like what I call America
Anarchy and uh it'll get pretty crazy
potentially an attempt one of the things
I talk about is an attempted Bitcoin
seizure
um like an executive order 6102 that
um puts half the you know puts the state
in a collision course with the network
and uh and that's the only way they can
Finance the government after years more
of printing and inflation and so on they
try to do some kind of Bitcoin seizure
and States resist this their states that
have passed anti-seizure bills this is
one scenario that's the American Anarchy
scenario where things get kind of crazy
there on the other side is Chinese
control and whether it's in response to
you know Roger Garside has this book
called China coup where he
um like you know basically talks about
how he thinks they'll be a coup in China
and democracy will take over whether
that coup happens organically or is
attempted by you know or or the US like
helps back it or whatever just like you
know bidencing Putin must you know leave
power or you know the various regime
change things that have been tried
whether it happens organically or it's
U.S backed or who knows some combination
if something like that is attempted
and Garside and others are kind of
advocating for it Source has kind of
talked about something like this the
China Crackdown will be in scene because
that's the thing they're set up to to go
against and they'll use AI to like rip
Civil Society out by The Roots You know
like anybody who's near anybody who's
possibly related to somebody involved in
some kind of crazy you know like like a
coup attempt it'll just be like ripped
out by The Roots You might see
nationalists Chinese nationalist mobs
running around on the Internet or even
in person against this and so they will
have a total potential Crackdown Chinese
control and uh in that scenario that
that software to control you know
basically the entire population then
gets exported to every country that
China has hard power in all these
African countries but also you know uh
lots of countries in sort of the Border
Zone
um that could swing in you know the
American or Chinese Direction and so
between these two things between
American Anarchy and Chinese control you
kind of want neither okay
um you know you don't don't you know
Anarchy is really bad Anarchy is uh in
my view something that people think is
good but you know even crypto Anarchy is
certainly better than nothing but it's
not that great and the reason it's not
that great is there's many Goods that
cannot be reduced to like a peer-to-peer
transaction yes I can buy bread or milk
or something like that potentially from
you but what I can't buy is a high trust
neighborhood and a peaceful walk through
the street without bullets whizzing
through past my head right like you know
if you've got have a guy in Syria and
he's got 10 million dollars in Bitcoin
you know what he wants he wants a ticket
out of there or he wants peace
um those are collective Goods maybe
obviously but this is something where
the totally peer-to-peer model of the
world doesn't account for those kind of
collective Goods where people all have
to sort of sacrifice some autonomy for a
collective good that everybody has it's
almost the opposite model of you know
the Communist who cannot see the need
for individual self-interest and they
only talk about the collective this is
the exact opposite of that which is only
talking about individual peer-to-peer
transactions and not talking about
anything that's you know Collective or
whatever okay so between these two
things between Anarchy and tyranny
between American Chinese control
I think we need to uh build a
recentralized center and the reason I
say recentralized is it's like the least
popular word on the planet okay why
because they're centralized and then
there's decentralized right so
centralized is the US establishment and
the CCP the CCP like with their
Crackdown and the US establishment
saying hey you know we may have printed
all these dollars who may have screwed
all this stuff up but we're still the
legitimate representative of the flag
you know why do you want to go into this
maximalist Anarchy that's you know
questionable as to what's going to
happen it could be really bad uh you
know this is our country you know we
want to fight fruit et cetera and that I
think is what I call the the green
faction if you take red versus blue and
you Splash yellow on both sides green
versus orange versus green is I think
where it lines up dollar green versus
Bitcoin orange and that's the green
factions narrative is centralization
just like the the CCP then against both
of those is the orange fraction BTC
which says decentralization says screw
you you guys you know like did the China
virus and you faked all the you know
news and you printed all this money and
you've minted all these cantillionaires
and
um you've basically built this entire
fake system
there's a lot of there's a lot of Merit
to this right there's a lot of Merit to
the concept that
um there has been a ton of fakery and
whatnot and then the issue is that that
gets taken to the point of no leaders
ever right all hierarchies are
illegitimate
um and you know it was saying like
Slayer heroes or something like that
which is basically you've heard this
kind of term no yes right so what that
is is something where the maximalist
actually overlaps with the woke where
they actually start to sound very
similar the woke says civility is tone
policing and the maximum says toxicity
is good right or you know the the woke
wants to abolish the police the Maximus
wants to you know uh you know abolish
the state and
um whether it's we are all equal or you
ain't the boss of me even though there's
tonal differences between them the
vector sum is uh nobody's in charge
right total Anarchy no leadership and
the thing is that the woke will
constantly talk about fascism Fashions
and fashion fashion and they'll Define
themselves as anti-fascists against the
upper right corner they signal against
that push to the lower left of the
political compass and what you're seeing
to a greater extent are folks who Define
themselves as anti-communist right and
of course I'm against communism but they
Define themselves as being against the
upper left corner and point into lower
right direction as Ultra Ultra Ultra
libertarian and when you take those two
vectors when you take things that kind
of Point like this uh the left and right
kind of cancel out but you have the the
sum is to the bottom right have you done
like vector math you know I'm talking
that uh that's nowhere near what you've
done but I know what it is you know what
it is right once you once you think like
oh actually these things
um they do disagree on many aspects but
they both agree on is nobody should be
in charge and the current order is
illegitimate and rotted and should go
away let me let me ask you about this
and uh we're gonna wade into uh a area
where I think there's plenty of people
who have lots of opinions uh both on the
walk side and also on the Bitcoin
maximalism side how much of this is
um
the Bitcoin maximalists care more about
being a maximalist than care about the
success of Bitcoin the won't care more
about the uh the kind of camaraderie of
everyone is woke together more than like
the actual impact of uh achieving their
goal like is it a replacement for
religion is it like the community and
cultural aspect of it ends up uh
transforming someone's identity and the
identity to this set of ideals is almost
more important than the actual intended
outcome or like how do you think about
that because to me that feels like they
both it's very important to them that
they are identified as part of the group
yeah so so I actually have this uh tweet
thread from a little while ago that you
might have there right like so basically
people who think they're supporting an
issue online I'm just gonna read this
okay for a second then discuss it many
folks who think they're supporting an
issue online are really just taking
direction from Twitter's algorithm
there's an unmistakable stylistic
convergence of many different ideologies
what is rewarded twitterism and what is
twitterism the sick burn the public Feud
the sarcastic meme the purity test the
hysterical mob some ideologies claim to
be for tolerance others preach order or
moderation but twitterism is none of
these and is what actually happens and
even if you personally try to resist
twitterism it doesn't matter the most
sarcastic tweets go viral it can be one
percent of your output but 100 of what
the world sees from you and so you know
there are good parts of Twitter but the
history increases variance it amplifies
the extreme good and bad and you know
Twitter is like a dispatch mechanism for
our attention the same way that Uber
dispatches drivers to writers and so the
thing is that people are kind of hill
climbing so you've heard of like number
go up technology right well what are the
Wilkes about they're about status quo
right books are you know like kind of
very roughly speaking and this is just
rough right but if you take the
left-hand side of the political Compass
they are more concerned with status and
you know academic position and political
Rank and politics and so on and the
right hand says becomes more
conservative economics and money and
markets and so and so forth very you
know high level right
and so status glove technology is you
know the books developed this entire set
of verbal armaments in Academia where
they could just like you know stab you
in it online as you're a white male haha
you know and what happens is it's like
redistribution of status in real time
you know and one way of thinking about
it is if communism was about the factory
floor and it was about the strike you
know and that was the collective action
where you could get the hated boss to
finally hand over all that money that
had been hoarding now what happened was
it meant that you suddenly actually had
a second boss which is a union boss and
you actually had a whole second group of
managers who are the you know mid-level
managers and now you actually had two
managers and you had to pay union dues
and it's not like the original company
went away it's just like this vampiric
thing got attached to it which is a
union and it sucked off you know some of
the money and it made the company less
competitive but it had the Optics of
like liberating the workers even if it
made it was like this Barnacle that
attached and didn't produce anything it
didn't take any risk just kept asking
for more money and made the company less
competitive fine okay so that was the
the thing though is that in the very
short run the group of union workers
were convinced that those strikes were
making them money even if in the medium
to long run it was dead in an invisible
way from the competitiveness of the
company even if it was actually making
them poorer in the medium to long run
from the union dues and the fact that
the union was then going to be
controlling their speech and the union
was going to be controlling their
promotions and all that stuff like even
if all that was true in the very short
run it gained the money and that's
actually one of the reasons that you
know unions proliferated it seemed to
give people a tangible good until in the
long run it didn't right and won't miss
is kind of like that wokeness it's not
the factory floor that's a setting
anymore because people aren't on the
factory floors part of their birthday
where are they on they're on the
internet right they're on the internet
they're on social media and so what is
wokeness it's a collective action by all
the people who accept those woke
premises to go and gang up on somebody
and they're taking not their money from
the boss but the status from the
oppressor
when people do this
um is there a a defense mechanism is
there a way for the the non-woke to uh
either resist to fight back to just
ignore like like how do you look at the
the other side of the equation
extremely good question and uh you know
I thought about this a lot and and
whatnot and in some ways it's it's
actually like a virus in its own way
where it had to partially like go
through the population for for you and
me to both know what wokeness is for the
audience to know what it is for us to
have a word for it I mean one thing by
the way the Wolves themselves didn't
come up with the word woke in fact they
hate it they try to scratch off the
label all the time right and it's funny
because everybody else is labeled with
something like wokeness is all about
coming up with labels
for everything else pathologizing it
problematizing it and so on and so forth
everything else is labeled and named and
analyzed and verbalized to very verbal
except for Brokenness itself right which
is sort of the you know um erasing
Indiana Jones like the scene where he
like swaps out the idol
um you know what I'm talking about yeah
yeah so wokeness is like the combination
of fecaldy and deconstruction with civil
rights ideology where it like takes away
it first says everything is relative
there's no morality and then this is
what's good right and it's basically
like a radicalized version of civil
rights you know kind of stuff but it's
not even uh equal rights it's just a it
is the Equal Rights what communism is to
treating your workers well you know it
is something that claims to be for that
but is actually not that
um you know a communist claim to treat
work as well but put them in the gulag
right wokeness you know claims to you
know treat people equally but you get
like you know BLM burning you know black
businesses down and so on right and so
the you know hopefully I can say this
because you know it's true and it's it's
something where you know if you look at
the history of Communism it was actually
terrible for workers you know by the end
you had this uh situation with
solidarity where solidarity was trying
to strike
I was actually part of what brought the
you know Soviet Union down is that they
were cracking down on the group that
they were supposed to be for you know
the workers Paradise the Soviet
unionists cracked down the workers this
I think is also going to be the big
problem with well capital and why it's
not going to live very long is all this
inflation that's happening all the
dollars that are being printed it's
hitting non-whites the hardest
right if you look at you know inflation
numbers you know the hill actually has a
study like inflation you know hitting
non-white people the hardest like
um so what's going to happen what's
already happening is it's hitting that
Coalition that they claim to be
enriching and speaking for is just like
the workers under communism were
actually
um impoverished and and harmed
um you know the printing under
vocabulism is going to hit and hurt
non-white people very very badly much
worse than they were under the previous
system
the pre-work system which had its flaws
but was better than weakness and so that
I do think is delegitimizing but then
that doesn't mean that anything that
replaces is necessarily good I I
certainly agree with the uh with the
maximalist critique of uh you know
inflation or things but I also do think
that the answer is not just total
decentralization crypto Anarchy but
rather recentralization under opt-in
leaders and some Maximus by the way
would I think agree with me on that
um but it's it's a spectrum it's just
like with wokeness
um you know where it is woke end and
simply just somebody who's liberal or
Progressive or whatever where does that
begin and it is that's the reason it
works right the reason it works is you
have somebody who is genuinely tolerant
and then somebody who says all the same
things but uses it to be intolerant the
last thing I'm going to say here and I
know uh we're running out of time a
little bit but
um
I always go back to this idea of so many
of the problems in the world and whether
it's uh Bitcoin maximalist or a uh kind
of uh fed critics or whoever they all
kind of arrive at the same conclusion
which is uh uh we don't have free
markets and free markets have kind of
been uh co-opted
um and taken over by ideologies by uh
these social focuses by uh everything
other than like free market capitalism
right and if you believe in free markets
and their ability to self-correct and
kind of eventually find the answer uh
optimizing for anything other than let
the free market do its thing uh is
obviously intervention and would prevent
the free market from from operating and
so
what I think is a unique uh way to
present Bitcoin or other types of
Technologies uh that follow some or eat
those is that it's trying to implement
free market dynamics again but do it in
a way where they cannot be co-opted like
yes somebody can go and manipulate the
Bitcoin price right but if you're just a
large holder or whatever but they cannot
change fundamentally what Bitcoin is
they cannot take over the network they
cannot change the programmatic monetary
policy they cannot do these things and
so it goes back to like the classic
Google like don't be evil can't be evil
right type uh uh uh nomenclature
if we were successful in implementing
free markets where people could not take
them over would the world be a better
place it's Up For Debate but I think
there's a strong argument that the free
market oh yeah will definitely leave
yourself correct okay so let's say that
I probably I probably agree with almost
you know with much of that right
the only thing is
um
do you know the difference between open
loop versus closed loop control no
okay so like in control theory
um let's say that you uh you had a car
okay and uh you close your eyes and you
just hit the gas okay that's like open
loop control there's no feedback okay
but closed loop control you have your
eyes open and you're looking at the road
and you're making micro Corrections and
steering the wheel left and right and
and so and so forth and so you're making
micro Corrections
um constantly sometimes a little bit
left sometimes a little bit right and uh
and that's keeping you on the straight
narrow to get there and if it's a
complicated and long Direction
um
you can't just
keep thing veering left or keep the
thing veering right and hope to get
there okay
um as as a second metaphor that I think
is also related imagine that somebody
was a westist why are they a westist
because they liked the idea of
California
okay so just kept going west
and they then they got to California and
then they they had people in the group
say we have to keep going west what are
you some kind of cuck you don't want to
be you know we got to keep going west
aren't you or west is right you're going
east now you're in California and so
then they keep going west they land the
Pacific Ocean okay and so the point is
that an ideology that is just a
Direction
is going to insist on a purity that is
actually a stupidity because you really
want to optimize for Destination not
consistent Direction
you can go too far left you can go too
far right you have to actually be able
to steer and so it may be the case that
at this point in time I agree that one
should see your right or steer left or
or up or down or something else right
like there's more than just two two
directions also but you have to have
some vision of what that destination is
and moreover as you know as a startup
investor just the words that somebody
writes in a slide deck there's a
thousand micro Corrections that they
have to make on the steering wheel ten
thousand hundred thousand between that
slide deck their words and their vision
and their actual destination you know
and so simply saying it on the Internet
it's like you know it's it's a starting
place
but the execution the implementation of
that concept require many pragmatic
compromises with reality and so that's
actually one of the things I talk about
in the book is basically I do believe in
moral entrepreneurship in the sense that
I do believe people should uh and I
think Tech entrepreneurs have actually
only done this implicitly it's not just
about a technological innovation it's
about a moral Innovation it's not just
about a failure in the market it's a
failure in society that one wants to fix
you don't just have something that is a
better mousetrap you have something
that's a better world but how do you
actually prove that that's actually a
good moral Innovation and not a bad one
because just like most tech companies
fail you know uh most most you know
things don't actually work in the market
many moral Innovations like the
Communists had a moral Innovation which
is profit bad The Profit used to be
considered good then they said hey let's
what happens if we say profit is bad it
turned out to be a very bad uh door to
go down but hundreds of millions of
people were enslaved 100 million died
before you fix that right other moral
Innovations like you know cigarettes bad
or smoking bad you know before
cigarettes are acceptable or even good
then flip to bad I argue that's probably
on balance a good intervention and then
yet still others like prohibition which
said alcohol bad and then got flipped
back to alcohol acceptable right that
was you know neutral to negative that
the prohibition thing but you can also
argue that alcohol does cause still a
lot of crimes DUI Etc so you can argue
that point maybe you want not a coercive
prohibition but a dry Society You could
argue that point okay so the thing is if
you have a moral Innovation if you have
a strong moral position then what you
want to do and I talk about this in the
book is build society as a service right
prove that you're right by actually
going let's see your Maximus you go and
build your Citadel and you you bring
people in society is a service and the
thousand things that can't fit in a
tweet all the decisions that you
actually have to make about a real
Society like what are the laws going to
be are there going to be police
um is there going to be any central
government of any kind all this type of
stuff you actually will have to go and
figure out out in your society as a
service and you'll have to make
pragmatic concessions to reality that
one does not if one is just you know
kind of popping off right and that's
kind of how I think about it is you want
to give people the ability to morally
innovate and technologically innovate
they build these society as a services
and the way that there's a check on
their legitimacy is that people choose
to come and they choose to stay and if
they don't like it they can choose to
leave and they can choose between others
of these kinds and uh you know they can
tour it online that's why the digital
component is so important they can tour
it online cheaply so they can go in
comparison shop and then find the best
ones but with that said I do think
there's a big difference between those
folks who will build these societies and
those folks who are the consumer you
know citizens I do think there's a good
thing about comparison shopping between
jurisdictions but that's like you know
the difference between buying an iPhone
building an iPhone is much harder and so
the folks who are going to build these
jurisdictions cannot simply be the
consumer citizen they have to be you
have to be much more missionary than
quote unquote you know mercenary right
um so this is how I think you can
actually prove that your online morality
is Right build a society oriented around
that see what it actually looks like
when you materialize it just like a
theory theory of you know math or
computer science actually sometimes need
to write the code to see if it works and
then you can show that it's attractive
and you've actually made the right
trade-offs or it might be something that
only works when you can be you know in
the back road throwing stones or online
throwing stones and it doesn't work if
you actually go and declare yourself
president of Historic Society and try
and build one
when you think about uh kind of these
theories as they continue to come
together
put a probability I don't know next 10
years what's the probability that we see
a network state in a 10-year period and
then what's the probability we see it in
a 50-year time period
it's a great question I mean I I want to
actually bring this into fruition so
um I'm playing on your rational and
optimistic sides sure sure well I mean
this thing as we've talked about there's
actually a lot of proof points towards
this we have billion person social
networks we have billion person
crowdfunds we have massive online
meetups we have uh you know remote work
and all this stuff is now mainstream we
have dissatisfaction with the
establishment blah blah there's like
many many different things where it's
quote just systems integration
but
um
I mean let me put it like this do I
think it is possible I mean 10 years ago
in 2012 I think you know what was the
price of Bitcoin is it was in it was 10
bucks or something like that right so a
lot can happen in 10 years
a lot enormous amount could happen in 20
years 20 years ago you know 2002 I mean
like that's I Google was around it's
true but it was pre-facebook it was
pre-iphone it was pretty a lot of things
um you know even the internet age as we
normally think about it really I think
only truly started post iPhone
um there's a great book on this or but
until basically 2008 Google you know it
was the only company was making money on
the internet Microsoft didn't really
think of the internet thought of Google
and apple was not solely an
international music Gadget company and
it was before Airbnb and Uber so all
this stuff this entire internet economy
is about like less than 15 years old
maybe 13 years old so an enormous amount
can happen in 10 years
and do I think it is possible that you
could have a startup society that you
know my face is by the way of emergence
are you have a startup society which is
a guy you know person declares himself
you know just like you declare yourself
CEO of a new startup company you're
you're still president of a new stop
society and if one person then you've
recruit people online for that you build
it to 10 and 100 and then you start
organizing them into what I call a
network Union which takes you know the
big difference to your network Union and
a normal online community is the network
Community is capable of collective
action seemed like a small thing it's
actually a huge thing it basically means
that they are combining to achieve a
goal and they're actually doing that
thing even if that's all just upvoting
something they start to actually get
accustomed to sacrificing for the group
and working together for a measurable
cause or the group is stronger than the
individual just getting 10 people to go
and you know help some member of the
network Union each day
um is a big deal and you might start to
have an internal currency of that
Network Union because they don't just do
normal Union things like
um they might help somebody if they've
got a conflict with their employer that
is a potential thing they could also do
like group purchasing they could help
somebody with a launch they could
um you know help and crowdfund something
they're basically like a online
community that that helps you out right
a network Union so that's digital you
get these people accustomed to doing
Collective actions building trust and so
on and eventually that networking takes
the next step to physical and what does
that mean they start crowdfunding
buildings maybe it's houses that two or
three or five people live together in
maybe it is apartment complexes that you
know if if you have a large Network
Union 100 people can buy an apartment
complex and suddenly they all have
equity in the building where they
wouldn't have had it before when you
have a hundred you know streams of rent
together you have a different
conversation with a building owner than
if you have one right and doing all this
means they have to sort of appoint a CEO
or a president of that Network Union
um it can't just be like an online
community that you know everybody's
there for Game of Thrones they actually
have some sort of collective leadership
so you go from startup Society to
network Union to what I call Network
archipelago that is This Global build
out of lots of little physical pieces of
territory that are knitted together and
then eventually if you have enough
population and enough income and enough
real estate footprint
you can gain the Diplomatic recognition
from an existing state required to
become a network State and that might
not be a sovereign like uh you know you
might not have a France or would I
recognize you you might start with a
small country like a tuvalu or a small
City even you know uh like in Miami
isn't that small City but
um you know a Texas or a Miami or two
you don't have to have a huge national
government do it you could have a state
or a city government or a small national
government
um do it and that first thing that first
recognition why do I think that's
possible because you do have tuvalu you
know signing deals with companies you
have Colombia signing deals with
companies for the dot TV and Dot Co
domains you have El Salvador doing the
Bitcoin deal uh you know the uh Bitcoin
is the national currency right uh you
have uh which is a big deal uh you have
um Wyoming doing the uh the ethereum Dow
loss they're integrated with the
ethereum network that right and so you
have many proof points like this where
you have states and cities and small
countries that are doing deals with
corporations or with networks and or
with um with other groups and so I do
think all of those proof points are
there and I think if you have a large
enough online entity that shows enough
longevity it's going to be rebuffed the
first time it's going to be laughed at
for years it's going to be thought to be
crazy but eventually 5 or 10 or 15 years
or sooner or later I don't know it will
have the scale I think to achieve
diplomatic recognition especially if
it's like more than a million people and
it's bigger than you know 20 of the
countries in the U.N
I mean it would be incredible if this
happens and I think your point about
there are many many proof points and uh
kind of mini Milestones that we can plot
out that this seems to be the direction
that we're going if people want to learn
more about the network State and read
the book where can we send them to uh to
find it and then where can we send
people to find you on the internet
great question so
um if you go to the networkstate.com so
yeah so theresa.com so first is that
subscribe widget in the lower left go
and subscribe because there'll be more
chapters free chapters and so on the
whole thing is free online you can read
online you can download the PDF if you
want it on Kindle for offline buy it on
Amazon
um I think it's a pretty decent
experience on uh on mobile so you know
your Android phones and so on so go
there and then otherwise uh go to
um
twitter.com biology s and you can follow
me and that is here and I will return to
tweeting soon yes I've just been I've
just been faving and rting and stuff
I've been warming up but uh
it's like it's like The Returned yeah
yeah something like that right
um so we wanted to basically uh if you
scroll up with it for a second in this
uh oh in the zoom oh yeah great so
that's me apology s
um yeah and uh if you go um I should
actually update the URL but if you go
back to the networksheet.com it's upper
left corner it's kind of a fun logo
right get a new country create button
create new country yes exactly right
click let's go all right listen now left
click this is left left click left click
left click okay uh listen thank you so
much for uh for taking the time to do
this I think that you and I could uh
could literally sit here I've actually
thought that you and I one day should
sit down and just go for 12 hours and
just see like how how much [ __ ] could we
actually talk about because I enjoyed
every single time when we when we get
the hardcover out there with the 600 700
Pages all the charts and stuff like that
we'll do a page flip and I'll just kind
of call out what I think is Page by Page
something like that there you go all
right well listen thank you so much for
taking the time to do this I know people
will have learned a lot I learned a lot
and I will definitely do it again in the
future that was a fantastic conversation
with Balaji I could talk to him for many
many more hours don't forget that these
episodes are brought to you by FTX us
FTX has very cheap trading fees
sometimes as much as 85 cheaper than any
of their competitors they also are
testing digital stock trading which will
allow people to buy stocks in app but it
won't have any transaction fees and no
payment for order flow go check out FTX
us today go click on the link in the
description and get started also give
you a bonus once you make your first
couple of Trades I hope that you enjoyed
this conversation with blushy and I'm
looking forward to doing many more with
him over the coming months